on a vu ça dans beaucoup de films de
science-fiction préserver le corps
humain en diminuant la température du
corps
mais pour la première fois cette semaine
ya des médecins américains qui ont tenté
l'expérience sur de vrais patients
hospitalisés pour des blessures graves
essayons d sujet qui a retenu
l'attention de renaud pour sa chronique
que 352 science bonjour nous et bonjour
quand même à ces méthodes qui pourraient
vraiment sauver des vies oui c'est
vraiment quelque chose que la de sortir
des films de science-fiction convient de
voir encadré imaginez vous avez un
patient est en arrêt cardiaque qui est
inconscient il est emmené à l'hôpital
d'urgence il ya été blessé par par
balles ou par armes blanches qui a perdu
beaucoup de sang dans ces conditions le
les médecins n'ont qu'une dizaine de
minutes au mieux pour stabiliser le
patient qui essaie lui sauver la vie
alors que l'oeil des chercheurs qui
disent que ces patients la passion
baisser leur température corporelle de
beaucoup l'on parle d'une dizaine de
degrés celsius on pourrait ralentir leur
métabolisme et la sai dizaine de minutes
locke que les chercheurs avaient pour y
traiter le patient se transforme en deux
heures donc on gagne du temps pour
traiter le patient c'est exactement soit
on augmente la durée de temps pour que
les médecins puissent faire leur
manipulation précis lui sauver la vie
donc c'est une procédure qui le froid on
a déjà essayé de l'utiliser pour traiter
les patients mais c'est quelque chose
qui fait dans certains hôpitaux baisser
sa température corporelle d'un ou deux
degrés une dizaine de degrés c'est
énorme on n'a jamais fait ça avant
c'est quelque chose qui très
expérimentale ça essayez d'une procédure
qui a été fait qui se fait présentement
à l'école de médecine de l'université du
maryland à baltimore donc que l'on
annoncé qu'il commençait ce projet de
recherche le lundi dernier ils ont su
l'autorisation de l'évier aux états unis
pour mettre en place ce projet de
recherche
ils ont dit qu'ils ont même traité un
premier patient avec cette méthode là
donc leur objectif c'est d'évaluer le
potentiel de ce traitement en comparant
dix patients qui ont été traités par le
froid avec dix personnes qui ont été
traités de façon normale pour voir si
s'améliore vraiment les chances de
survie
ils vont annoncer les résultats de cette
étude en 2020 qu'est ce qu'on s'est
concrètement comment ça fonctionne
ils ont donné les grandes lignes de la
procédure ils ont ils ont donné un nom
spel préservation et ressuscite à sion
est l'objectif de cette méthode là c'est
vraiment protéger des organes vitaux le
comme le coeur ou le cerveau qui risque
de manquer d'oxygène dans ce genre de
situation là donc ce qu'on sait que de
la procédure c'est que
d'abord les chercheurs dont on voit ici
saucisses qui en temps normal les
organes vitaux manque d'oxygène
ils ont justement quelques minutes pour
opérer lorsque les chercheurs vont faire
ceux qui vont d'abord retiré le sang de
la personne blessée et lui donner la
place une solution saline très froide
pour baisser rapidement la température
corporelle de 10 à 15 degrés donc à ces
niveaux là le coeur vont arrêter de
battre le cerveau va fonctionner mais de
façon minimale mais maintenant ça va
ralentir les processus moléculaires dans
le corps de la personne donc dont la
dégradation des organes et c'est ça qui
vont venir donner le temps
supplémentaire aux patients et qu'il
faut permettre aux médecins de leur
sauver la vie
donc une fois qu'une fois que la
procédure terminée on augmente lentement
la température on redonne aux patients
du sens normal et cela qu'on voit si on
lui a sauvé la vie ou non donc ça fait
15 ans qu'on pratique ce genre de
traitement l'eau sur des animaux et là
maintenant on est rendu à le transférer
chez l'humain c'est l'étape où on est
rendu
c'est sûr que c'est pas une étape d'une
procédure qui sans risque ici possible
qu'il ait dommages cellulaires qui
puisse se faire
mais vu qu'on l'a fait uniquement chez
des patients qui ont 5 % de chances de
survie des patients qui sont vraiment ou
à l'article de la mort si ça fonctionne
ça pourrait révolutionner la
traumatologie dans les hôpitaux et c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'un peu de
fantastique ici qui est en train d'être
essayé la bonne ça qu'on va continue de
suivre ça et j'avais vraiment j'adore en
voir les résultats en 2020 c'est clair
dans les autres sujets qui retiennent
l'attention cette semaine c'est
les découvertes archéologiques très
importante au pérou et ça c'est dû à
l'intelligence artificielle oui c'est
des chercheurs qui ont travaillé sur les
lignes de nasca donc ça c'est des images
donc dès qu'on appelle des géoglyphes
des images vieille de 2000 ans qui ont
été tracées dans le sol de cette de
cette vallée lot xiii aride au pérou qui
l'a validé qui est près de la ville de
nascar donc c'est ses dessins la cdac
des formes convoiterait pouvoir tracer
dans le sol ici ça c'est celle qu'on
connaît les images classiques qu'on
connaissait déjà
donc on trouve d'habitude des animaux
des formes étranges certaines plantes
certains de ces formules peuvent avoir
quelques dizaines de mètres de longueur
d'autres c'est des centaines simplement
atteindre le demi kilomètre donc c'est
les formes qui sont gigantesques et on
peut uniquement très bien les voir à
partir du ciel donc c'est ça qui fait
que on les voit uniquement de peu qu'on
les a découverts uniquement depuis la
découverte de l'avion 20e siècle donc
ces formules des fois sont difficiles à
voir on peut le voir ici à l'écran
mais peuvent être difficiles mais dont
il s'est formé peut être effets peuvent
avoir été effacées par le temps donc
c'est là qu'arrive de cette équipe une
équipe de chercheurs japonais qui s'est
associé avec aille bien pour qui
travaille qui ont utilisé une
intelligence artificielle pour passer à
travers des centaines d' images
satellite pour essayer de tout devoir de
distinguer ses formes la queue dès juin
va rater avant qu'on a du mal à
distinguer l'onu mais cet cette
intelligence artificielle a vraiment été
entraîné pour reconnaître ses formes là
comme on peut voir ici l'image haut le
sol avant et qu'est ce que
l'intelligence artificielle à distinguer
c'est cette espèce de formula donc ce
qu'on voit c'est des images qui sont
très étranges et les chercheurs espèrent
que ben on en trouvant des nouvelles on
autrui 143 nouvelles grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle on va finir
par essayer de comprendre c'est quoi
l'utilité de ces formats pourquoi ces
légendes dessiner ce combat livré un
message peut faire aux flux envoyait ses
défis ses formules ont été sont au
patrimoine de l'unesco depuis 1994 et le
ces formules sont tous deux sont allés
l'y rejoindre et là maintenant on espère
vraiment qu'on vaut mieux les comprendre
qu'en mettant ça montre à quel point
l'intelligence artificielle peut venir
aider les chercheurs et faire des
découvertes l'eau du bain ne sont pas
capables de distinguer ce genre de
formule 1 ou dans ce domaine là où en
terminant dans les nous de la sonde de
la nasa dans l'antarctique cette semaine
qu'on va suivre si un test voici que
c'est quelque chose on va suivre parce
que ça va avoir une importance dans les
prochaines années ce ne sont que on la
voit à l'écran en ce moment la nasa le
vote a commencé une étude cette semaine
ils vont ils ont plaît amenez sous les
glaces de l'arctique pour l'attester
dans ce genre de conditions sous marines
et une première sonde sous marine que la
nasa veut utiliser et son importance ici
parce que ça vient en lien avec une
autre découverte qui devrait arriver
cette semaine c'est le dos d'une énorme
quantité d'eau sur des lunes de jupiter
comme l'europe
on pense que les océans sur cette
planète là donc si on veut les explorer
un jour il va nous falloir ce genre de
son bleu donc on les teste tout de suite
et peut-être dans les années 2020 on va
les envoyer là bas pour commencer
explorer des océans sur d'autres
planètes
donc c'est des choses qui vont être à
suivre dans les prochaines entraînement
extrême entraînements et la nasa survie
pour des robots c'est fait